Enrico Matias dans une chanson qu'il a
composé avec Alain Barrière Enrico
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Matias
s'il fallait tout donner de ma modeste
gloire les larmes et le FE et le S
pouvoir écrire quelques années
d'histoire je donnerai
toutésit un
instanter rest rien une vie tout entière
jamais prtiquer toutes mes ambitions moi
je resterai rien jusqu'à n cimetière si
la vie revenait à tous mes
compagnons mais bien
sûr on se
perd dans le grand tourbillon
[Musique]
des
folies des erreurs des crimes et des
passions on s'est perdu bien sûr où
était la raison et le regret demeure
au-delà des
chansons mais pouvoir tout donner de ma
modeste
vie jamais et le feu et le sol et
pouvoir écrire quelques années
d'histoire oui je donnerai tout ou tout
à cet
instant rester rien une vie tout
entièretiqué toutes mes ambitions moi je
resterai rien jusqu'à mon cimetière si
la vie revenait à tous mes
compagnons mais bien
sûr je le
sais on n peut rien
changer le é é
tiré il a fallu le
boire sur la route
aujourd'hui il faut se
retrouver pour y croire à nouveau et
puis toujours y
croire s'il fallait rester rien une vie
tout
entière fatiquer toutes mes ambitions
moi je resterai rien jusqu'à mon
cimetière si la vie revenait à tous mes
compagnons si la vie
revenait à tous mes
[Musique]
compagnons